[Music]
today we got another ask citizens of Joe
Mallya and today we have Marcela Silva
here and she has a question for us she
says forget about coal vide right now
are you guys proud of how much you've
accomplished so far in life once all of
you has hit 60 do you think you have
reached your goals or do you feel like
you have an infinite amount of things
you want to do stay safe
I definitely feel like I have an
infinite amount of things I want to do
like one of them is still making the
movie with everyone here I want to drink
more water that's a good one but I do
feel I do you feel like I'm pretty proud
of what I've done because I think I've
already surpassed what I've ever thought
I was gonna be able to do what do you
think was your max like you know like
when we first started JK and I wanted to
go the whole pre-med route and then I
realized I really enjoyed content and
making I mean a brilliant comedy making
content with Joe we're a brainstorming
like what jobs could we do that we're
more on the like traditional tip so we
can do a comedy on the side and we're
talking about being like a nurse or
being like a police officer or whatever
so in my mind at that time being like
early to mid-20s I was already cemented
having like a 50 to 60 K job and then
working like three by 12 or four by 10
and they're just doing comedy with Joe
so for you hitting that and more
monetarily is what you felt like you
surpassed yeah and then like I never
thought we were gonna I thought we might
have like one small little office or me
and Joe just face each other we had a
spot we have this small little office
right here yeah but like being able to
have an office and to have even like we
built like all these channels and have
JK party and Jackie party like even
though it's rad JK style and it's crazy
it's actually a legit soundstage you
know it's like soundproof there's
[ __ ] trust systems it's just
everything because things weren't
officialized the Hollywood Way it still
felt like like a ragtag group but it's a
legit soundstage that we built in the
middle of downtown LA and it's just
crazy when we think back about all the
stuff that we did on My Damn
that's way past what what I what I would
have a sure like everything else is just
bonus points yeah everything with this
point on this bone is so like even
though I have a huge want to make a
movie if I never do
unlike that's cool too because it's
already way past what I want but I do
really really want to [ __ ] that will
make a movie yeah or make ten movies
exactly I don't know if I feel
accomplished and satisfied I do agree
though like I'm sir I serve as more than
I thought was possible yeah cuz my goal
was like I just want a [ __ ] Dodge
Challenger
alright I remember that give me a Dodge
Challenger great car and a [ __ ]
two-bedroom apartment and I'm set I
remember the day when so me and Joe
always talked about our dream cars and
it was like I wanted a Corvette you
wanted a Dodge Challenger in and I
remember the day that I think we were
like talking to Greg who is our
financial advisor and then taxes around
the corner and he was like hey guys you
guys need to like spend some money to
deduct these taxes at a Joe's like so
you mean we can get a Dodge Challenger
and then I remember him going you need
something a little bit more expensive
and he was like my dreams went like [ __ ]
call it shows an adult I think that
whole night we were just watching
YouTube videos and just watching like
these like motor trends like race videos
of sports car just kept linking them to
each other yeah I was like top notch
cars but it's crazy that once you
surpass something the thing that you
want you thought you wanted so bad yeah
it doesn't hit you anymore and that's
where I agree like people are like all
the material things I think it just
makes you happy for that second and it
goes away yeah yeah but to be even even
get there I think that's an
accomplishment cuz most people really
can't like you just dream about it right
so you don't know what that feels but to
be able to go there get there and then
experience it and then really say yeah I
know what it means like you buy
something and then it's temporary
happiness and then you don't really care
about it anymore it's like oh it's
really true were you thinking the whole
time I think I can do this or were you
just doing it I was just doing exactly
and then you look back
and you go wow I did all this [ __ ]
that's what people don't understand them
all this [ __ ] I don't even know if I had
confidence I don't even what confidence
was I think I think we're just doing it
oh I had a like I was like I hope one
day I'll get this car I was just doing
all this [ __ ] and that's how I got to
where and then one day I turned around I
was like oh [ __ ] I did all that that's
crazy
I've been in rooms with billionaires
I've talked to [ __ ] tons of people
famous people all this stuff I've been a
writer writing rooms with household
names and I thought that they didn't
have very good bits because I didn't
think they were trying that hard because
I think that they got comfortable and so
it's like damn dude like I don't think
anyone's that great because I think that
everyone just kids kind of doing [ __ ]
and then they look back at their
accomplishments like wow I did a [ __ ]
crush do a little bit huh yes I think
there's a difference between identifying
with accomplishments and what fulfills
you you know how they say like there's a
difference between fulfillment and
achievement right and I think a lot of
people focus on the achievement part of
things and then they they think that
that's gonna bring them the happiness
but in reality that never does but it's
just a it's just a way to get somewhere
so people that haven't achieved much I
think they still have this mentality of
like oh when is it when is it where you
look back and you're satisfied and I
think for me I'm never satisfied in that
sense because I'm gonna find new things
to want to accomplish but then do I have
fulfillment is yeah I could die right
now yeah I mean I guess it depends on
how you define success is it one
singular thing or is it one general idea
that applies to a lot of things everyone
has their own definition of success cuz
they could just be like I get to spend a
lot of time with my family and that
makes me successful I have the have a
house I work and then on the weekends I
[ __ ] have a blast and I love it I've
talked to people like that or you get to
commit war crimes they get or get away
with them I smell all the oil of this
country didn't go to jail
success success yes it's that success
kid meme I steer economies in certain
ways while buying stock in certain ways
I left office and I'm richer than [ __ ]
I'm bailing out the
United States while I get some for me
and my company success what about what
about you guys do you guys feel like
you're you satisfied or you guys or you
guys separate you guys on the same page
I don't know where you're at but for me
personally I like what you were saying I
definitely do not feel like I've
accomplished anything actually but I do
feel very fulfilled like I'm very happy
with my life and I do get those moments
of like what Steve was saying where I do
kind of like look back and I'm like ah
there's a lot for me like I have been
like feeling very satisfied and content
with the life that I have had all along
even though there's there's like
struggles or whatever and like hard
times but then in those hard times I
really appreciate because it makes me
really love the good times which it's
all it all makes me feel like I overall
I have a happy good life like I have no
complaints you have no complaints Casey
attest to that Fox here no I'm kidding
but no even everything like honestly
everything cuz we still obviously have
our freakin problems but if in the end
it's always good because then we get to
learn more about each other and then we
grow and we're growing together
it's not like it's tearing us apart
you know I have like that big dream like
that big goal of wanting to make a movie
and being like like you know like this
is the ego speaking like being a figure
in the film industry and all that kind
of stuff but I always kind of looked at
it like it's a like these days I look at
it as like a target to hit and and along
the way though of getting to that target
it's you have a lot even up along the
side and and then I I really enjoy those
doors I come up along the way and open
the doors and let oh snap I met my best
friends oh cool and then we created
companies and stuff with them and we
made skits and stuff Oh open this door
oh [ __ ] I met my wife and then I open
this door about a house and you know
it's like oh [ __ ] I have a life now and
it's so much more fulfilling so I think
for me and like success is not so much
like we achieving the
the thing that you want most at the top
of the mountain but more or less you
know enjoying this things that come up
come along the way yeah i neva know I'd
be a writer when I was a kid how about
that I had no [ __ ] idea to talk about
stumbling into things along the way I
had no [ __ ] clue attention in English
I would have it I wanted to be a pirate
right till fifth grade fifth grade dude
I wanted to be a pirate they thought I
was crazy yeah well I even just thought
I was like I just want to do comedy some
I didn't know that writing was even a
part of that I was doing yucks did you
want to be funny yeah boy yeah right so
then you find all this other stuff on
the way there was no YouTube back then
so it's just like all this [ __ ] got
created later and then you just find it
you know what though like for me all
along I have been feeling like I've been
feeling like conflicted
because because of like I guess that's
the Seidel pressures or whatever you
must have a passion and I I don't feel
like I've ever really felt a passion for
anything particularly like and I just
stumbled into this like this is my
career like this is what I do to make
money and it's just like I don't know
the fact that I've never really found
that thing that it's like this is my
passion
don't you like small things it's not
passion like what if it's this big it's
very short-lived that like oh that's it
oh so it's not really a passion you know
yeah these some people obsess over
certain things and just get deep and
want to do something and other people
are like they kind of vacation through
through ideas or whatever yeah I don't
think you have to because yeah when
you're when you're feeling good it was
not having it where I'm like yeah I'm
fine that's what I'm saying like I end
up like realizing like oh [ __ ] wait I've
been so fixated on the fact that I don't
have a passion like am I am i failing as
a person because I don't have this great
achievement or whatever but then I
realize like no I've been pretty happy
and content and fulfilled with my life
like I'm fine like and you might find
out when you least expect it to it's
like some people open bed and breakfast
when they're 50 and they love it or
whatever you don't know when you're
gonna find your thing doing it because
you feel that you're a loser if you
don't you're doing it for other people
still passions
never happened because it's for other
people it's usually because you're
obsessed with something because you're
in love with it who would have thought
that Joe Rogan would be the biggest name
in the world like when he was on
Newsradio and I was doing Fear Factor
who the [ __ ] would have thought that not
even he would tell you the number one
podcaster like who's he invent like he
it's like a new industry where you kind
of have to invent your own format he's
the Johnny Carson of now where if you're
on his show you're a household name so
it's like that's that kind of a
phenomenon nobody could have guessed
that [ __ ] any stumble yeah and even he
said he started over 10 years ago and
even he said when he was doing it
there's like barely any views like you
it wasn't like okay this is my path to
like conquering the world he was just
always doing it cuz I just wanted to
record I have a bunch of really cool
friends and I don't have conversations
with them and share and they just blew
up with this huge thing and he was
passionate about it was years of just
[ __ ] views for a long time with really
shitty quality quality like recording or
whatever yeah and that's the that's the
dedication parties I think people don't
realize is that like projecting news
like we did this for several years
before it started picking up and we just
did it because we enjoyed it so we don't
look at it as like okay in five years we
got to get here and then this it's still
robotic
[Music]
[Music]